oh you know it's fun that's bad
being up since 6:00 a.m. coughing every
few minutes and it's currently 4:30 in
the afternoon which means that it's
almost Showtime here but I hate to say
it and it's becoming a goddamn meme at
this point but I'm sick again I got
better from the last sickness my voice
is doing much better than it was and yet
I'm getting sick again because I've got
this persistent cough I don't know what
the hell's wrong with me
but I'm gonna do the smart thing for
once in my goddamn life I am going to
take the time that I need to get healthy
and I'm gonna focus on just that and
getting plenty of sleep and taking lots
of showers and drinking lots of tea
what does that mean for you guys that
means it unfortunately I'm gonna put a
pause on the daily vlogs and the other
improv game so we had scheduled and I'm
going to just 100% focus on what I had
to do with the show right here and then
I will be back once I am feeling better
I don't I keep saying this over and over
and over again and I hate to be a broken
record about this but I am just goddamn
sick and tired of being sick so I'm
gonna take the time I need I'm gonna
kick this sicknesses ass and then I'm
gonna kick my own ass and get out on
that stage and do a great show and then
I'm gonna stop coughing over once oh my
god damn oh I hate it so much anyway so
I'm gonna go get better and then I'm
gonna go to the show and I'm gonna sleep
for like ten million years so see you
guys soon love you bye